[Applauso]
quando veniamo a conoscenza di un
segreto è generalmente stupiamo i
bambini dicendo loro me l'ha detto un
uccellino in realtà chi è soltanto
capace di ripetere le stesse cose viene
in genere avvitato più o meno come un
pappagallo secondo la cultura contadina
le rondini sono degli animali sacri
invece la civetta è portatrice di
sventura il mozambico alcune tribù hanno
imparato a dialogare con i passeri per
andare con loro alla ricerca di miele
figure come icaro piuttosto che leonardo
da vinci si sono ispirate al volo degli
uccelli hanno sognato di poter sfilare
finalmente volare i corvi della nuova
caledonia hanno una capacità di
astrazione incredibile loro si
fabbricano utilizzando da rametti e
foglie gli strumenti necessari per
andare alla ricerca di cibo
ora questo presuppone una capacità
cognitiva enorme perché perché in realtà
lo sanno fare semplicemente per aver
visto altri corvi utilizzare gli
strumenti ovvero sanno costruire i loro
strumenti di lavoro pur non avendo mai
visto il processo necessario a poterli
fabbricare ora questo fenomeno è
interessantissimo perché permette
l'evoluzione stessa degli strumenti di
lavoro e anche l'evoluzione stessa della
specie dei corvi e in realtà questo
questo fenomeno si riteneva solo un puro
appannaggio della della specie umana
basandomi su su questo che vi chiedo di
frugare all'interno della vostra borsa
ted cercate guardate dentro c'è una
piccola busta
ok su cui c'è scritto aspetta ad aprire
dentro a questa busta ci trovate sei
mattoncini colorati
siccome appunto vi ha detto i corvi
sanno fabbricarsi i loro strumenti pur
non avendo mai visto le istruzioni
necessarie a poterlo fare l'esperimento
che faremo qui dentro è di cercare di
e la stessa cosa pensate a una papera
voi avete mai visto una papera dal vivo
se non l'avete la vista dal vivo di
sicuro l'avete vista in qualche
documentario l'avete vista nei cartoni
animati l'avete vista nei fumetti ok
com'è fatta una papera come sono fatte
le sue zampe come è fatto il suo becco
il suo collo volo non vola una papera ok
immaginatela costruite da nella vostra
mente ora vi chiedo con i sei pezzettini
con i sei mattoncini che avete tra le
mani di costruire una papera non copiate
dai vostri vicini vi da tempo più o meno
un minuto
montate i vostri 6 mattoncini e
costruite una papera prego quando avete
finito di costruirla sollevate là in
alto così posso vedere che ha finito ora
vi chiedo richiede un po di attenzione
perché questa parte è estremamente
divertente allora osservate osservate le
vostre papere e osservate le proprie dei
vostri vicini tenetele su internet le
sue si sa no paper e uguali i vostri
vicini hanno fatto delle papere uguali
alla vostra
ciò che vi ho fatto fare un esercizio
estremamente interessante ovvero mi ha
fatto costruire una papera non vi ho
dato le istruzioni per poterlo fare
vi ho chiesto di osservare le papere non
vi ha detto che poteva esistere una
papera giusta e una papera sbagliata e
probabilmente se l'è osservassimo bene
gran parte delle papere all'interno di
questo teatro sono diverse tra di loro
ok in realtà ciò che vi ho chiesto di
fare è qualcosa di più
vi ho chiesto di sfruttare il vostro
modello mentale di paper a tutti voi
avete in testa un modello mentale di che
cosa sia una papera ovvero avete
osservato le papere nella realtà le pa
prende la realtà sono molteplici
ok ci siano paperi di tanti tipi diversi
ma voi avete sintetizzate nella vostra
testa e semplificata in un modello ora
il vostro modello non contiene tutti i
dettagli di una papera non sapere
esattamente quante più me a una papera
non lo so ma il vostro modello è
sufficiente a poter distinguere una
papera down e da un airone o da un gallo
ora ci sono persone che innovano
esattamente come avete fatto voi ovvero
sanno osservare la realtà si rendono
conto che la realtà è molteplice e
riescono a sintetizzare in testa dei
modelli che gli permettono di produrre a
loro volta dei prodotti o dei servizi da
consegnare all'umanità che siano nuovi
che siano mai visti prima e soprattutto
che migliorino la vita degli esseri
umani
la creatività spinge in questo la vostra
creatività vi ha portato a fare un
numero altissimo di papere diverse vi
faccio fare un esercizio in più questo
disegno è uno dei tanti studi di pablo
picasso in cui ha cercato di studiare e
semplificare il modo in cui potesse
essere rappresentata la realtà e tramite
un semplice tratto una semplice linea è
riuscito a produrre quello che
effettivamente può essere facilmente
identificato come un gallo ora che
processo e questo è un processo di
ulteriore semplificazione i modelli
mentali sono come
dissi mi perché ci permettono davvero da
un semplice tratto da un semplice
dettaglio di poter decifrare la realtà
ci sono persone che innovano in questo
modo ovvero sanno guardare nel profondo
delle cose o meglio sanno guardare nel
profondo dell'animo delle persone sanno
cogliere quali è qual è l'essenza dei
vostri sogni
qual è l'essenza di ciò che vi piace di
più qual è l'essenza della felicità e la
riescono a sintetizzare in qualcosa che
chiamiamo comunemente un'icona ovvero un
prodotto un servizio qualcosa che
utilizzate che li conoscete da un
semplice tratto rendiamo più complicato
e divertente il nostro esercizio
se vi avessi chiesto di costruire una
non papera che cosa avreste costruito
sareste partiti da un progetto avreste
cominciato a muovere mani
aumenta la difficoltà severi si chiede
di spiegare al vostro vicino di posto
che cosa sia un aereoplano e lui non lo
avesse mai visto belli avreste detto un
aeroplano è una cosa più o meno simile a
una papera ok può avere lo stesso colore
di una papera vola più o meno come una
papera non fa l'uovo ok quindi a volte
cerchiamo di utilizzare i modelli
mentali per spiegare agli altri qualcosa
che loro non hanno mai visto aumento la
difficoltà se vi avessi chiesto di
raccontare al vostro vicino di posto un
qualcosa che non esiste nella realtà ma
che vorreste fare perché è la vostra il
vostro prodotto innovativo che cosa li
avreste raccontato beh la difficoltà
aumenta è difficile pensare nella vostra
testa decifrare ci apre state pensando
ed è ancora più difficile raccontarlo
agli altri o farvi aiutare da gli altri
ci sono persone che innovano
in questo modo ovvero riescono a
concepire nella loro testa prodotti
servizi innovazioni così nuove dando ad
essere non soltanto difficili da pensare
ma anche difficili da raccontare agli
altri
ora come fanno queste persone come fanno
a riuscire a portare a bordo
dopo altre persone come fanno a
raccontare tutto questo beh sono persone
che hanno capito appieno come funzionano
i nostri tempi sono persone che li
stanno cavalcare sono persone che hanno
capito che il cambiamento è la misura
dei tempi di oggi perché perché i tempi
di oggi sono caratterizzati dalla
velocità che cosa significa tempi veloci
tempi veloci sono tempi in cui ti sembra
sempre perennemente di essere in ritardo
certo o sono quei tempi in cui per chi
si trova a dover fare prodotti e servizi
arrivo sul mercato sempre un po troppo
tardi se i nostri tempi sono veloci ci
hanno anche permesso di rendersi di
renderci conto di un'altra cosa ovvero
che i tempi in cui viviamo sono non
lineari che cosa significa non lineari
ve lo spiego con un esempio
provate a pensare ai vostri nonni quanti
cambiamenti epocali avranno vissuto
nella loro vita
certo alcuni cambiamenti vissuti dai
vostri nonni probabilmente sono stati
davvero epocali e stravolgenti per
l'intera umanità davvero impattanti ma
quanti in tutto forse cinque forse 10
nella loro vita i loro nonni quanti ne
avranno vissuto forse di meno ora
pensate a voi pensate ai vostri figli
gli analisti dicono che nei prossimi 20
anni
il genere umano cambierà più di quanto
non abbia fatto negli scorsi tre cento
quindi che cosa significa che il nostro
tempo e non lineare significa che non
segue articolo strina linea retta
la linea retta e quella che ti fa
pensare che domani andrà più o meno come
oggi e come ieri ma è chiaro a tutti che
in realtà alcune linee non sono rette
sono esponenziali se non addirittura
completamente imprevedibili impreviste i
nostri tempi poi sono complessi che cosa
significa complesso complesso significa
che la quantità di relazioni tra le
parti è talmente alta da non permetterci
di semplificare è complessa alla natura
pensate alla foresta pensate agli
ecosistemi naturali e complesso il corpo
umano e complesso il nostro cervello non
è così facile non è neppure possibile
isolare una parte e semplificare ora
ciò che è importante all'interno della
complessità e che appunto le reti e le
relazioni nessuno la misura davvero
importante e interessante e ultima cosa
i nostri tempi sono caratterizzati
dall'imprevedibilità ora
l'imprevedibilità è sempre stata
considerata spesso stata considerata
dalle nostre aziende come un qualcosa di
negativo abbiamo cercato di pianificare
ogni cosa c'è sempre spaventato pensare
che il futuro sia imprevedibile
in realtà l'imprevedibilità è un
buonissimo motore di innovazione
ce lo racconta darwin ci racconta che è
l'imprevedibilità permettere alle specie
di evolversi e di adattarsi al mondo in
cui stiamo vivendo ora quindi come fare
io nella mia esperienza ho avuto modo di
poter incontrare centinaia di
imprenditori che si stanno facendo
questa domanda alcuni hanno capito come
fare altri non lo sanno alcuni ci
riescono
altri non ci riescono tutti riconoscono
che è estremamente difficile ma c'è
un'altra cosa che invece io riconosco in
tutti loro e sono due caratteristiche
che accomunano le persone che cercano di
innovare oggi e sono una deliberata
sconfinata un desiderio fortissimo una
voglia fortissima di poter fare
sperimentazione e di nuovo una
deliberata e sconfinata un desiderio
fortissimo di poter disimparare che cosa
significano queste due cose
ora ci siamo detti il mondo di oggi i
nostri tempi sono caratterizzate
dall'incertezza e l'incertezza è una
misura positiva dei nostri tempi
ora se sei in certo che cosa puoi fare
come ti puoi comportare come puoi fare
se non puoi prevedere sempre tutto
un'idea buona e cominciare a scommettere
anziché promettere e per scommettere
bene una buona idea è di cominciare a
muoverci un passo dopo l'altro
ovvero faccio un piccolo passo verso la
direzione in cui penso di voler andare
poi mi chiedo come sta andando
se mi chiedo come sta andando lo chiedo
anche gli altri questo capita che
presuppone una estrema gentilezza nei
confronti di noi stessi e delle altre
persone ovvero devo davvero accettare di
domandarmi come sta andando
ora non vi sto dicendo che tutto è allo
sbando davvero non vi sta dicendo che
andare a caso è più o meno come muoversi
con un obiettivo ma mi sta dicendo che
gli obiettivi si raggiungono per piccoli
passi tramite i quali continuare a
imparare questa cosa dell'imparare è un
secondo termine è estremamente
importante ovvero per anni abbiamo
trasformato le nostre organizzazioni in
learning organization cioè abbiamo
cominciato a pensare che imparare fosse
una misura buona per poterci muovere nei
nostri tempi ed è vero per fortuna è
stato così per fortuna ci siamo resi
conto che imparare è importante ma a un
certo punto è anche successo e lo fanno
alcune delle aziende con cui lavoro che
tutto ciò che avevano imparato
chiamateli dati o chiamate di big data
tutto ciò che avevano imparato ogni
tanto li ha fatti pensare di poter
predire il futuro
l'uomo da sempre ha sperato di poter
predire il futuro ma in realtà predire
il futuro lo sappiamo non si può fare
non riusciamo neppure a predire che
tempo farà domani per cui probabilmente
anziché concentrarvi su come diventare
learning organization ciò che vi voglio
proporre e di concentrarvi su come
diventare learning organization ovvero a
volte è più difficile disimparare che
imparare disimparare significa spostarsi
in una condizione di leggero disagio
guardare il mondo guardare le cose che
stai facendo e renderti conto che forse
ciò che avevo imparato per ieri e per
oggi
oggi non vale più per domani ovvero non
puoi riapplicare vecchie regole a mondi
nuovi e disimparare fa spazio a un nuovo
imparare serve molto coraggio per
poterlo fare è davvero una sfida
entusiasmante per il mondo
dell'imprenditoria ma anche per il mondo
al di fuori del mondo del lavoro
magari è ciò che ha fatto invece
normalmente nella vostra vita portatelo
nel vostro mondo del lavoro perché le ho
lasciate confinato allo spazio al di
fuori del vostro lavoro
ora la domanda importante per tutti noi
però è quella che ci siamo fatti
all'inizio ovvero
voi che tipo di innovatori siete siete
innovatori che guardano il mondo e
riconoscono quanto e variopinto e sanno
aggiungere prodotti nuovi per creare
ancora più felicità o sette innovatori
che sanno guardare nel profondo
dell'essere umano e riconoscerne i
tratti fondamentali che accomunano tutte
le persone e e produrre quelle che
chiamiamo appunto dell'icone siete
innovatori che sanno fare esperimenti
sapete sperimentare ed essere gentili
nei confronti dei risultati dei vostri
esperimenti o sette innovatori che sanno
disimparare e quindi che ogni tanto
riconoscono di poter lasciare alcune
vecchie tradizioni per far spazio a
nuove idee e nuove modalità qualsiasi
tipo di innovatori voi siate
il motivo per cui lo fate è importante
ovvero nella mia esperienza vero
innovatori che in genere non innovano
solo per se stessi e non innovano
neppure per l'innovazione è fine a se
stessa non innovi perso lo per
modificare dei processi e non innovi
neppure soltanto per guadagnare di più
il motivo principale per cui novi è la
linfa vitale dell'innovazione è la
quantità di relazioni che ha saputo
creare attorno a te è la linfa che spi
ti spinge a voler innovare ed è anche la
misura di quanto bravo sei stato a farlo
più relazioni ai più innoverà i e più
relazione ai più ha innovato non è mai
esistito prima un periodo un momento
migliore per poter fare innovazione e in
realtà se non mi credete
ritirate sulle vostre opere che avete
costruito ascoltate questa cosa
ascoltate il sorriso che vi è nato sul
volto quando le avevate costruito
ascoltate il sorriso che è nato sul
volto delle persone che l'avevano
costruite vicino a voi
ecco questa è la misura di quanto oggi
valga la pena di innovare e creare nuove
relazioni
grazie
[Applauso]